ABCs of AI U is for unsupervised
learning a type of artificial
intelligence that learns from data
without human supervision okay but first
what is supervised learning well it's a
type of machine learning in which
algorithms are trained using a data set
of labeled examples so unsupervised
machine learning models are given
unlabeled data and allowed to discover
patterns and insights without any
explicit guidance or instruction
unsupervised learning is a great tool
for exploring and understanding data
without pre-existing labels you'll see
unsupervised learning often used for
broaden anomaly detection exploratory
data analysis customer segmentation
recommendation systems and so much more
so if you're looking to uncover hidden
patterns and relationships in your data
that would be difficult to discover
manually unsupervised learning is the
way to go we'll see you on the next
episode of